[Musica]
vi parlerò di un problema molto
complesso Oggi infatti sentiamo
continuamente parlare del problema delle
api e tutti quanti fanno a gara per
salvare le api
In primo luogo quello che bisogna
chiarire per parlare di un problema così
complesso e cosa intendiamo per api e se
vogliamo salvare qualcuno qualcosa
Dobbiamo capire in primo luogo chi è
allora quando noi parliamo di api spesso
incorriamo in un errore fatale Cioè
quello di rivolgerci a una delle 25.000
specie di api che noi conosciamo oggi al
mondo e cioè l'appe mellifera l'ape
cosiddetta occidentale l'ape gestita
dagli apicoltori attraverso l'apicoltura
ma noi abbiamo api solitarie api
gregarie api sociali con società
temporanee come quello dei Bombi e poi
api sociali con società permanenti come
L'Ape mellifera e altre api quelle dette
prive di pungiglione che vivono negli
ambienti tropicali un altro aspetto poi
che viene spesso confuso È quello delle
api e dell'apicoltura salvare le api
significa salvare l'apicoltura non
sempre le due cose coincidono Allora per
prima cosa cerchiamo di capire cosa sono
le api le api sono degli imenotteri cioè
insetti con due paia di Ali membrane che
però hanno una specializzazione vengono
dette apoidei antofili perché sono
perfettamente e assolutamente legati ai
fiori il loro percorso evolutivo
comincia circa 100 milioni di anni fa
Poco dopo la comparsa delle Magnolie
fitte che sono piante che hanno avuto
dei vantaggi fisiologici dall'evoluzione
per cui hanno scombinato le carte dei
panorami vegetali fino ad allora avevamo
delle masse enormi di piante quelle che
oggi ci fanno soffrire perché i depositi
di petrolio e di gas derivano da Queste
piante però Queste piante Erano tanti
Individui e poche specie E allora la
riproduzione era basata sul trasporto
del polline o delle cellule germinali
mediato dall'acqua o dal vento quando
arrivano le magnolie fitte queste si
dividono in tantissime specie E allora
in ogni ambiente le specie sono così
tante che una riproduzione casuale Non
funziona più allora con i meccanismi
dell'evoluzione tentativi su lunghi PSP
il fenomeno il processo della
impollinazione zoofila cioè degli
animali vanno su un fiore vi trovano
qualcosa di interessante e poi vanno su
un altro fiore della stessa specie
Perché nel frattempo le piante per
fidelizzare questi organismi hanno
inventato la pubblicità il colore la
forma e il profumo dei fiori sono la
pubblicità la reclame e il nettare è
l'offerta speciale sono i giga i
messaggi illimitati che dir si voglia le
api non discendono da questi più antichi
impollinatori ma dicendolo da vespe che
andavano a cacciare questi impollinatori
solo che l'evoluzione è bizzarra e ha
fornito questi alcune specie di questi
imenotteri di una peluria particolare li
ha trasformati in degli Spolverini
volanti questa peluria piumata fa sì che
con l'attrito dell'aria agli urti del
pulviscolo atmosferico l'energia
impressa dal volo questi insetti si
caricano di una carica elettrostatica
positiva i fiori che hanno la presa a
terra Cioè la radice hanno una carica
elettrostatica negativa Allora volando
sui fiori queste api si imbrattano di
Polline e quindi cominciano a ripulirsi
e l'evoluzione gli dà degli strumenti
per poi accumulare il polline morale
della favola questi insetti sono
diventati non solo tra i più diffusi e
importanti impollinatori No noi
conosciamo impollinatori le farfalle i
coleotteri molte mosche eccetera ma
questi altri insetti terminano diciamo
il loro lavoro di impollinatori sui
fiori e l'insetto adulto che va alla
ricerca o di Polline o di nettere per
avere l'energia per accoppiarsi e poi
deporre le uova su una pianta di cavolo
su una carota su del legno marcescente
invece le api proprio per questa grande
capacità di raccogliere il polline hanno
basato tutta la loro alimentazione sul
polline e anche sul nettare dal punto di
vista energetico per cui a me piace
usare questa immagine un po'
fanciullesca Io dico che le api sono
fiori con le ali e i fiori sono delle
api con le radici perché questi
organismi sono estremamente legati tra
di loro ora veniamo al secondo problema
no oggi
si parla sempre di catastrofi l'abbiamo
sentito anche in altre presentazioni
oggi quindi per dire che c'è un problema
Deve essere o la Vespa Killer o la
strage o qualcosa si sta estinguendo
Allora io faccio sempre riferimento a un
essere umano no Sì la morte è un
problema ma anche se ti amputano un
braccio una gamba due gambe tutte
diciamo così le conoscenze non è una
bella cosa allora non è solo
l'estinzione Il problema è anche la
riduzione del numero di specie del
numero di individui e poi quali api si
stanno estinguendo e dove si stanno
estinguendo Allora noi sappiamo che
molte delle 25.000 specie di api sono
minacciate di estinzione Perché i loro
habitat vengono distrutti Perché i loro
siti di nidificazione vengono distrutti
ci sono poi delle altre specie che
vedono ridotta la loro popolazione che
vedono disgiunti divisi i loro reali e
quindi dei problemi di
diversità e genetica eccetera
Qualcuno dice che l'ape mellifera non è
certo un organismo che si sta
estinguendo perché il numero di alveari
nel mondo sta aumentando sempre più ora
Questo è un modo di leggere le cose
molto semplicistico intanto L'ape
mellifera è un animale domestico o no
non è un animale domestico è un animale
selvatico che l'uomo riesce ad allevare
il branzino viene allevato Ma nessuno si
sogna di dire che il branzino è
domestico la pernice viene allevata ma
nessuno si sogna di dire che la pernice
è domestica ora ci sono degli animali
allevati che in natura si estinguono
Ecco il problema dell'Ape mellifera è
che il numero di colonie presenti nelle
armi e degli apicoltori e oggi in Europa
La maggior parte mentre che hanno
rischiato di estinguersi sono le colonie
che vivono ancora allo stato Selvaggio
ma di questo vi parlerò tra un attimo
ora voglio parlare dei problemi di
conservazione delle api di tutte le api
è un problema Veramente complesso perché
quel fenomeno definito secondo me in
maniera corretta come declino delle api
è un fenomeno che si diciamo dipana in
tantissime problematiche prima fra tutte
è la modificazione degli Habitat e della
Flora Noi facciamo fatica ad accorgerci
di quanto povero floristicamente sia
oggi il nostro territorio finché non
alleviamo delle api e chi come me alleva
le api da oltre 30 anni si rende conto
che questa diversità floristica sta
precipitando sta precipitando non ci
sono quasi più fiori Oggi tutti dicono
bisogna piantare alberi Ma dove bisogna
piantare gli alberi se oggi noi abbiamo
di emergenza ecologica è la perdita di
ambienti prativi
alberi mancano in certe città ma anche
nella Pianura Padana Ma se voi prendete
una foto degli anni 50 Di questi luoghi
delle Colline dove abito io a Isola
Vicentina eccetera vediamo che gli
alberi stanno rivestendo e anche qui
purtroppo venendo suo ho visto molti
Pascoli abbandonati ricoperti da eroi a
questo Poi questa perdita di Habitat è
data da un lato dall'abbandono
dall'altro dall'incremento dell'attività
umana quindi le monoculture e con le
monoculture i pesticidi i pesticidi oggi
sono un problema gravissimo non solo
perché il loro effetto negli ambienti
agrari rende impossibile la
sopravvivenza di una biodiversità anche
funzionale all'agricoltura pensate che
la apicoltura oggi è l'alibi perché
l'agricoltura possa usare decidi se non
ci fossero api allevate non sarebbe
possibile usare tutti i pesticidi che
noi usiamo perché oltre un terzo C'è chi
dice la metà di quello che mangiamo
dipende da un servizio di impollinazione
oggi la maggior parte degli ambienti
agrari sono sterili e quindi quella
settimana quei 15 giorni in cui la
cultura fiorisce bisogna portare Api da
fuori poi ci sono le modificazioni
climatiche che stanno devastando il
rapporto di animali così strettamente
legati a delle a delle fioriture e poi
c'è anche un altro problema che è stato
messo in luce recentemente su cui oggi
Gli scienziati sono tutti concordi per
le specie allevate di api c'è il
problema di un inquinamento genetico
l'ape mellifera che è natura
originariamente distribuita tra Europa
Africa e Medio Oriente è suddivisa in
oltre 30 sottospecie bene gli
sviluppatori europei e poi americani
sudamericani eccetera hanno cominciato a
tentare di risolvere i problemi
derivanti dall'ambiente E dai pesticidi
all'apicoltura
selezionando api spostando l'ape di qua
la metto di là eccetera e questo sta
disgregando la struttura genetica
dell'Ape e dell'Ape mellifera quindi
oggi si assiste diciamo a un'analisi di
questi problemi della conservazione
delle apiche da un lato poco chiara
superficiale in alcuni casi anche
schizofrenica perché noi abbiamo che gli
ambientalisti naturalisti sono
preoccupati delle
25.000 specie meno una la pellicola e
considerano l'ape mellifera un problema
per le altre api perché ci sarebbe una
competizione eccetera eccetera anche
questo tema della competizione tra le
api allevate e le api non allevate è un
problema che va visto caso per caso
negli Stati Uniti L'ape mellifera è
stata portata nel 1600 e ha una
competizione con le altre api di un
certo tipo ma negli ambienti in cui
l'agricoltura intensiva Ha bisogno di
impollinazione non entra Certamente in
competizione con altre specie locali di
api Allora l'ape vedete è allo stesso
tempo sia lupo che agnello perché è
agnello in quanto è un animale allevato
dall'uomo funzionale all'uomo per le
produzioni agricole e per la produzione
di quegli straordinari prodotti che ci
danno le api miele il polline la pappa
reale La propoli eccetera ma è anche
lupo perché è una componente degli
ecosistemi naturali Allora lo sa bene
chi studia i lupi e la difficile
convivenza con la Pastorizia o
l'allevamento ecco
interagire tutelare un animale che è
allo stesso tempo funzionale per la
nostra sopravvivenza Ma che ha una sua
identità biologica e un suo posto nella
natura è difficile se non si accetta che
sono esattamente la stessa cosa che io
non posso andare in una direzione per
tutelare l'apicoltura o l'allevamento
dei Bombi che mi servono per produrre i
pomodori e poi invece dall'altro lato
nelle aree naturali nelle riserve tutelo
le api in un'altra maniera o lo si fa
allo stesso modo o non si va da nessuna
parte perché l'ape mellifera una di
queste 25.000 specie e delle oltre mille
specie che vivono in Italia non è una
specie qualunque di queste api è una
specie che ha la capacità di impollinare
miliardi di fiori in un anno perché le
api di un alveare si spostano
fino a 3 km mediamente ma possono
arrivare anche a 10 12 km e quindi un
singolo alveare ha una capacità di
impollinare una Flora vastissima fino
all'80% Delle specie vegetali che
necessitano in impollinazione in tutto
il mondo anche in luoghi dove l'ape
mellifera non c'è mai stata possono
essere impollinate dall'ape mellifera
Ecco che allora oggi si sta prestando
attenzione alle colonie selvagge di ape
mellifera perché non sono una pecora
scappata dal gregge una vacca scappata
dalla stalla ma sono un'entità naturale
che vive nel suo ambiente e queste api
oggi anche gli apicoltori stanno capendo
che sono una risorsa Allora potremmo
anche parlare di quanto l'apicoltura sia
patrimonio della nostra cultura
l'apicoltura è antichissima
testimoniata da migliaia di anni fa ha
contribuito alla scienza allo sviluppo
delle conoscenze scientifiche e naturali
e anche l'apicoltura va tutelata allora
tutti vogliono salvare le api ma molto
spesso queste azioni così dimostrative
di grandi aziende piccoli aziende gruppi
di ambientalisti è un po' Saltare su sul
carro del vincitore è un green washing
Diciamo in cui spesso le cose proposte
sono peggiori del problema stesso ad
esempio c'è chi vende delle api come dei
giocattoli didattici no Ecco che allora
ti mandano a casa i bozzoletti dell'Ape
che magari proviene dalla Svizzera o
dalla Germania e tu sei al ventesimo
piano di un grattacielo a Milano e le
metti lì e le vedi volare finché muoiono
di fame queste Ecco non è dignitoso non
è etico giocare con questi animali con
tutti gli animali e
il fatto poi che la tutela delle api sia
invece qualcosa di complicato e di
complesso al motivo per cui io ho
cercato di raccontarvi anche Cosa sono
queste api Allora la tutela delle api si
deve basare su tutta una serie di scelte
che certamente coinvolgono la politica
perché tutti parlano del problema dei
pesticidi poi se andiamo a Bruxelles ci
sono più rappresentanti delle case di
agrofarmaci che non Parlamentari a
tutelare diciamo così l'ambiente e oggi
noi siamo di fronte a un periodo
elettorale cerchiamo di capire chi pone
i temi ambientali chi pone i temi della
conservazione della biodiversità come
programma elettorale perché questo
riguarda tutti noi ma riguarda tutti noi
Anche quello che si può fare
quotidianamente per salvare le api
allora ogni singolo cittadino oltre che
la sua scelta elettorale la sua delega
alla classe politica può con le sue
scelte quotidiane modificare certe cose
quando io compro un cibo mi devo
chiedere ma per produrre Questo cibo
Quanti pesticidi sono stati utilizzati
da quanto lontano viene questo prodotto
Quanto è stato pagato l'agricoltore che
ha prodotto questo alimento Il
sottocosto è nemico della biodiversità
ed è nemico della sostenibilità perché
solo una retribuzione dignitosa può
permettere all'agricoltura di andare
sempre più avanti verso la sostenibilità
Ecco che allora le nostre scelte
quotidiane dove andiamo in ferie che
tipo di casa Ci costruiamo Che tipo di
veicolo guidiamo sono
veramente importanti anche come gestiamo
il nostro giardino o come chiediamo alla
nostra amministrazione comunale di
gestire il giardino faccio un esempio
banale e poi chiudo dietro a casa mia
hanno fatto una pista ciclabile Dove il
comune ha chiesto a un gruppo di persone
che si occupano della natura del nostro
paese dice cosa facciamo seminiamo un
miscuglio di piante autoctone e tariffe
e lasciamo quello che è fuori dalla
pista ciclabile per la natura per la
biodiversità bene quando c'è stata la
fioritura dei Papaveri dei Fiordalisi
tutti a fare i post a farsi i selfie nel
gruppo sei di Isola Vicentina Ma che
belli sti fiori eccetera Poi quando i
fiori sono seccati Ma che schifo il
comune deve intervenire ora un fiore
secco è perché si è trasformato in semi
e quei semi in parte garantiranno la
riproduzione della pianta in parte
nutriranno gli uccelli eccetera eccetera
no il Comune se non se non ha finché non
ha tagliato sta roba la cittadinanza non
è stata contenta allora anche noi il
nostro prato inglese Mettiamolo di
plastica a sto punto allora non dobbiamo
neanche diserbarlo perché il prato
inglese sta alla biodiversità come la
situazione attuale sta alla pace nel
mondo diciamo così
quindi
scusate
quindi ritornando alle api l'importanza
ulteriore delle api e che il meccanismo
spesso sottovalutato dell'impollinazione
ci dà una lezione straordinaria è una
cosa sembra banale l'impollinazione No
perché invece ci dice che due organismi
completamente diversi
hanno bisogno l'uno dell'altro per la
propria sopravvivenza le api ci
insegnano la legge fondamentale della
natura che deve esserci complessità se
non c'è complessità non c'è vita E
questa la biodiversità Allora bisogna
che passiamo dal fatto che tutti
vogliono salvare le api al fatto che
ognuno di noi deve fare qualcosa per
salvare le api Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]